hey guys I'm Lisa from the store eSports
only one week into the 2017 spring split
playoffs and we've already had to
reverse sweeps over in the EU LCS
misfits came back from a - Oh deficit to
take down slice and across the pond in
na LCS fly quest reverse swept CLG these
series have inspired us to look back and
count down the top 10 most epic reverse
sweeps in the history of legal legends
coming in at number 10 is cloud 9 taking
down Team Liquid in the semi-finals of
the 2015 na LCS spring playoff cloud 9
coming back with three straight wins the
champion selects of Game three being a
huge boon for them and playing on the
mentality of Team Liquid cloud 9
takedown team liquid to move on coming
in at number 9 on our list is SKT taking
down CJ entus in round 2 of the 2015 Oh
G and spring split down the junior green
wings 3 oh and now they pay italic opted
a and a best-of-five and if we are
fortunate enough to make it all the way
to game number 5 it is blind pick one
game away from CJ moving on to the
finals SKT turned the tables around
taking a series on the back of bang and
morons big play comes in space jumped in
to try to clean this one up
meanwhile faker though still untouched
bang doing a lot of damage Coco gets the
kill awesome bengi Oh bang gets the kill
the bad light though they're turning it
around bar it comes back in and SK
Telecom turns around the team by bang
faker gets the kill and this may be
another turret going down in favor of SK
Telecom there goes the Nexus and CJ
taken down SK Telecom comes back from o2
the reverse sweep to send them to the
Grand Finals against GE Tigers
SK Telecom and this is just what they do
this loss marked the start of a steady
decline for CJ while SKT would move on
to defeat the Tigers and attend the
midseason Invitational number 8 on our
list goes to HTT a reverse sweep of sk
gaming in the third-place match of the
2015 spring flip
lay off expectations for SK gaming at
that time we're very high with the
roster consisting of star players like
Spence Garin and forgiving on the other
hand it was h2k first slid in the EU LCS
but they managed to qualify for playoffs
anyways so when the squad of rookies won
against the powerhouse of SK things
started out pretty much as expected any
wave comes through and a lot of members
of SK gaming here's yarn it makes me
serious damage to star is going to go
down on the hunt is bot looking for
forgiving they won't find yardage Oh
Garrett sunflower takes our first bucks
he might have got a little too far but
h2k too squishy take up the dragons
descent photo op it equalizes that kill
scores however the newcomers reverse the
momentum and took down SK in dramatic
fashion they're going to turn their
attention on fine and radix box is going
to be the one law company take it down
after the exhausting monsoon out onto
things keeping the ball i freddy is
going to be the next to fall this time
in sol LULAC all rio he's going for fox
right now he might have got too far for
it hops dues done his hourglass and he's
got anyway he's going to punch away
hydrated got it a lot such a mix it's
just too much
hat yardage picks up at guys like kill
Freddy now on the retreat Rio somehow
still staying alive goes up hotel-motel
stop getting before how about our triple
and we're going for inhibitors again
this series marks the start of easter
keys rise of an EU LCS contender and was
an inglorious finish to what should have
been s JS crowning split
coming in seventh on our list is LCL
team Alvis los lunas victory over vega
squadron to earn their spot at the 2016
international wildcard qualifier vega
squadron was set to punch their own
ticket to the IWC qualifier but Albus
Knox was not to be denied in Game three
the poor player lucrative out his
signature brand and the rest of the
teams played out of their minds
come on a bit more ready plantation
planets are not available to shop for
only doesn't figure where you thank you
exactly by felucca particle okay buddy
if you try to move up
Albus knock eventually took the series
to secure their spot in the wild-card
qualifier there they took down lion
gaming in the final of the tournament by
qualifying the world's and proceeded to
do what many thought was impossible for
a wild-card team no not just yet Rock
all these fingers are heading to point
links those inaccurate jaws see the
craters rise oh and also we can't forget
this moment
all I want to say is that hey guys we
are from wild carp and they have told
you before being underdog doesn't mean
being a loser
our number six reverse sweep comes from
the lck with kt rolster taking down
powerhouse @k p in the 2016 summer split
playoffs after time SKT had won two
world championship titles and were
without a doubt the best team in the
world their tournament has just been so
clean it took almost all the way to the
finals who we saw any of these unforced
errors and there are only a couple of
them
the only team that was expected to stand
a chance against SKT was the beloved Rox
Tigers that prophecy was on track to
come true but despite SKT being up two
games ke pede bit back and proceeded to
take them down now
gdb coming up rope fly gonna try to get
the chase on but going to be two people
but next it over the wall flashes it
still gets the frozen tube down does
come up with the first loss nicely done
by flight doesn't get punished yet
actually able to make it out other
guardian angel sitting upon that back
from you could be trying to stick it to
the back sit on the next is it KK well
sir they're gonna do what they take down
SK Telecom in the reverse sweep bringing
it back number five on our list is
unicorns of love and the reverse sweep
of millennium in the 2015 spring sled
promotion tournament despite earning a
shot at promotion with their confident
win over ni P and it's the unicorns of
love with a three Oh domination over the
ninjas in pyjamas you will well
initially found themselves struggling
against a veteran millenium squad this
is going to be the game the 8th credit
goes to JRE that now millenia are one
game away for Bri entering the European
LCS however you will well does beat into
their bag of tricks
turning the tide with visit Rocky's
pocket pop what ok
visit shop be locked in poppy top here
comes to Jaime can he get the flam yes
he gets the first kill and wow a double
kill the ad carry for docks no he stays
alive created for the chachi
again is effective down he goes CH 0
seven poppy for business chachi
undefeated universe of love pull it in
the game for and to keep their hope for
the LCF alive and eventually go on to
complete the comeback is it enough
he's trying to Canada oh my god I got it
well just get a cordless phone to the
LCF less than one year after its
formation you'll well had earned a spot
in the LCS and while the roster has
changed since then
players like visit chachi and Hill a
song still remain on the squad can you
imagine what the EU LCS would look like
without the beloved unicorn taking the
number four spot on our list is lmq the
speeding team cursed in the 2014 summer
trip playoff the winner will take third
place and lock in the last spot in North
America to compete against the world's
best in the 2014 World Championship the
fancy record came out swinging continues
Kansas be the damage for first
possibility he's going to go down shall
we shout drop
- 4 0 3 4 0 who I curse were only one
win away from securing their spot at
Worlds for the first time ever
but lmq fought back forcing the series
to go the distance in this series
because they're constantly going to say
bye shall we shall there's a great
problem and they find their way out of a
special and no-name joint won 4-0 so far
no they going mental in this by 5 I will
dominate that is for all because the
live this could be the Alec you bear is
impossible as well and triple for no
name on kha'zix and LMG are in complete
control
lmq you're headed to the World
Championship
lmq defeated curse and went on to
compete in the 2014 World Championship
from challenger to North American
representative in the World Championship
in a split their loss ultimately lost
Kurtz in fourth place once again and
call for a dramatic shake-up of the
franchise the first continue this series
also spawned a now-famous League of
Legends reverse sweep dream which was
the past Wiggins results is more
relevant than ever coming in at number
three on our list is clgs reverse sweep
of curse Academy to stay in the NA LCS
despite a strong start in the 2014
summer split Bill G's performance
plummeted and they finish in 5th place
if they LG has been obtained in turmoil
I feel G again performed poorly in
playoff and after losing to Dignitas
we're forced to fight for their LCS
lives in the 2015 spring flips motion
tournament game three Dignitas take the
best of five series against powder logic
gaming
konna logic gaming now the promo
relegation tournament to face a
challenger series team that has come out
on top and they're looking for their way
in and to the LCS when it comes down to
it now we're here to bring you our next
matchup which is between counter logic
gaming Gus Heather things didn't look
good for CLG he's going to go down
that's going to be a wonderful one in
the bottom line but Cubs Academy
Walraven chocolate immediately deleting
CLG off this map tombola first down
triple kill 15 and they get the baron
3000 gold is almost release double it
down a lot of horsefly was incredible
manages to catch him out with the flat
as well bunny foo foo is ago I'm putting
it out right here that was possibly
something but they fought back valiantly
to win when it mattered most and hold on
to their spots me nal pho then with a
three game straight being down two games
to begin with this is a success story
they all looking for papers that they
can come back
[ __ ] my god
what making their second appearance on
our list is cloud nine with their
miracle gauntlet run in the summer of
2015 after a mixed bag of results cloud
nine were unable to qualify for world
through championship points the team had
a rough early start to the split and
made a late run to climb out of ninth
and into seven saving hi no longer cloud
ninth place meaning that they would have
to go through the regional final
and that's when c9 pulled off the
impossible by an incarnation case where
that was happening he's really thinking
just look how taking he is takes about
every ultimate last kill in the real
coming out for gravity and they're still
able to take him down a double kill
coming in for sneaky that's a kill
already for incarnation on the fight if
I pick one up for himself
everybody's getting their hands in this
one and they are able to come back from
b2 Oh
or I should say Oh to that gravity put
them in to go three two two versus
gravity in the first call it game of the
North American summer split cloud nine
are moving on to take on involved
teleports come in that's balls in the
front line that was actually really paid
for thought over and they're looking for
a high a half health already but as a
barrage damage Russia's alive pop guilty
stays afloat there's a poke back
Ignatian to have an income sneaky he
wants to follow but it's going to be
enough yes it is the kill picks up four
c9 is going some hotel first Nikki it is
against gravity they might just do it
here against team impulse 25 second the
refund here they go
next is turret number one where's the
defense it's up there impulse have to
give up the base they give up the game
they give up the series cloud nine get
through first sweep and there
face Team Liquid cloud nine has one
final opponent and if they win at their
third consecutive World Championship
appearances this might be the push to
send cloud nine the world champion theme
second here comes ion and to the back
line he goes doesn't find a champion but
the turrets are in front already Donna
take the pine dominate take the javelin
turret one is gone - Rick you under fire
piglets up in four there's the knockin
but there's the captions the ad he takes
about cost is dead on to the Nexus they
go a double for sneaky piglets back up a
piglet slow down chat bye-bye sometimes
it's Phoenix is funny whoever cannot
kill them off Ingrid Asians owns a
mountain that's going to be the Nexus
this secures them a spot at Worlds at
the third seat and cemented high
reputation as one of North America's
best in-game leader they should almost
can't believe it from seventh place in
the regular season
toes blowing Wow taking our number one
spot is the epic series between SK
Telecom t1 and the kt rolster bullet in
the summer split playoffs of 2013 at the
time of this series it was only s
Katie's second professional split with a
roster including familiar names like
piglet impact and faker coming into this
match Katie were Korea's super team and
kicked off the series with a 200 lead
putting them one game away from
qualifying the world yeah I feel like if
they go you are obscure yeah coming it
over the top
in fact is right there though needs to
be careful yeah no super minion
that'll be an accessory and there goes a
necklace Gigi however as Katie would not
go down coming in from behind
it was the explosive cap so carefully
here strike this maven toss later pushes
away in fact oh he doesn't have a flat
pack over he's a classic ELISA goal okay
she's not bras here's the ultimate slam
dunk on to Rio they push them all the
way back
piglets no live get to kill he paused
the barrier double kill
/ faker Sarah is hot sweaty minutes
forever in Game three they took the
theory to a fist game which meant that
the champions would be blind picks Ryu
and Baker both chose said gifting us the
iconic duel between the two even though
I only have a battle before I think
exhibit bad opaque or maybe a trouble
your deaf art prize the green up for you
oh look at the quiz look at the boat
thank you
why was that thank you was a human LASIK
she wasn't I can't believe I'm sorry
actually what that joy SKT went on to
defeat Katy in the final game in 37
minutes sending it over the top of
scores
traps piglet get the kill goes onto
faker faker snacks off a bit and look at
ryu he knows it's over champion summer
is over
SK Telecom coming back after being two
down
there goes a nexus DD incredible reverse
bull kill coming out of SK Telecom
getting shovel with this victory SKT
qualified for the 2013 World
Championship and went on to take home
its first ever world title
and there you have it those were our
picks for the top 10 most epic reverse
weeks do you agree or disagree with our
list let us know in the comments below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]